elvin is part of a series of events
puzzling investigators nine shark
attacks along the southeast florida
coast in 2017
more than double the average and with
leads coming up short
some local authorities come up with
their own theories for the spike
vero beach ocean rescue's eric tomsu
explains
in my experience it's based on a few
different issues people in the water
number one number two
how clear the water is usually there's
murky water when we've had an incident
murky water it seems like an innocuous
detail
but witness jessica veach echoes the
idea that it's important
there's a lot of sand being churned
which makes it hard for the shark to see
what is actually fighting
could the shark's ability to see in
murky water be the one thing that ties
all the attacks together
according to dr huber sharks are adept
at navigating murky water
relying on other senses
in murky water sharks can lean more
heavily upon the lateral line and the
electro sensory systems in order to
locate their prey
but he does think there is a unique
limit to a shark's vision
that could have played a role in some of
the attacks
and it has to do with available light
we're bringing out a spiny dogfish
to investigate dr huber performs an eye
dissection
using this common shark found in waters
all over the world
getting towards the back of the eyeball
we'll be able to free it up
and remove it from the skull
this is the back half of the eyeball one
of the really interesting things about
shark's eyes is that they have a layer
of reflective crystals that coat the
back of the eye
with a thing called a tapitum lucidum
and what this does is it actually causes
night shine you may have seen night
shine on your cat or your dog on a
variety of different animals
in humans light passes through the eye
once
but for sharks in dark waters the
taffidum lucidum
bounces the light back letting the eye
process
images a second time in layman's terms
this basically means that sharks have
night vision
but as the sun begins to rise a shark's
eye must react to the increasing light
you can think of when you first open
your eyes in the morning and things seem
a little bit too bright
after a few seconds your eyes
accommodate to the amount of light in
the room and then you can see things as
you normally would
[Music]
and in sharks this process can take
anywhere from a half an hour to
potentially a couple of hours
it's a process called visual
accommodation
during these periods of changing light
like dusk
or dawn a shark's vision may be
compromised
potentially leaving swimmers vulnerable
during these times sharks are very very
active looking for their prey
which would increase the probability of
a shark attack if people were in the
water at those same times
[Music]
[Music]
you